das ist eine spektakuläre these eines us
wissenschaftlers läuft unsere intensive
suche nach außerirdischem leben etwa so
erfolglos weil das leben auf der erde
ein absoluter einzelfall immer alles mit
hilfe eines supercomputers komplett zu
dem ergebnis dass das leben auf der erde
wohl einen großen zufall zu verdanken
ist die existenz außerirdischen lebens
also damit ausgeschlossen
kriegswirtschaft bis dreimal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
ihr habt das möglich gemacht clixoom ist
in die top 30 podcast wissenschaft in
deutschland aufgestiegen und in
österreich in den top-20 erwiesen dank
an euch aber es lohnt sich auch wirklich
für unterwegs im auto auf dem fahrrad in
der u-bahn und so weiter und so fort
also wenn nicht jetzt waren dann klickt
auf die links spotify und apple podcast
in der video beschreibung und hier und
damit möglicherweise hat es das
schicksal richtig gut mit uns menschen
gemeint davon geht zumindest der
us-wissenschaftler tobi teil aus er hat
sich intensiv mit der spannenden
forschungsfrage auseinandergesetzt ob
und inwieweit planeten die existenz von
leben auf ihn über lange zeiträume
hinweg ermöglichen
in der fachsprache ist von der
sogenannten habitablen eines planeten
die sprache und so gilt ein planet als
habit abel wenn auf im leben über einen
längeren zeitraum hinweg
aufrechterhalten werden kann für das
leben wie wir es bisher kennen muss
beispielsweise energie für die
reproduktion und den stoffwechsel der
lebewesen bereitgestellt werden im fall
der erde ist es der aktuellen studie
zufolge purer zufall dass sie leben
bereits seit so langer zeit möglich
macht und dass sich menschen irgendein x
entwickelt haben
doch was bedeutet dieses ergebnis für
die suche nach außerirdischem leben ist
sie deswegen von vornherein zum
scheitern verurteilt und sind wir
wirklich allein im all
genau darum geht es jetzt eigentlich
sind fachleute weltweit so gut wie
sicher dass außerirdisches leben
existiert und das ist nur eine frage der
zeit ist wann wir dieses endlich auch
spüren bereits vor 60 jahren hatte der
physiker frank drake eine
berechnungsmethode entwickelt um die
anzahl intelligenter lebensform in der
milchstraße zu ermitteln dazu der usa so
am samstag vom seti institute in einem
universum mit millionen galaxien wäre es
ziemlich vermessen anzunehmen dass nur
die erde allein intelligente kreaturen
hervorgebracht hat ein forschungsteam
aus england hat quasi die drake
gleichung 2.0 aufgestellt und kam dabei
zu einem überraschenden ergebnis demnach
leben in der milchstraße neben der
menschheit achtung 35 weitere
intelligente lebensform diese
zivilisation sind nach ansicht des
forschungsteams in der lage aktiv zu
kommunizieren und diese berechnung ist
alles andere als unwissenschaftlich ganz
im gegenteil denn sie basiert auf daten
die astronomie teams in den vergangenen
jahrzehnten über die milchstraße sammeln
konnten einen platz in der neuen drake
gleichung fanden so einige faktoren
unter anderem die gesamtzahl der sterne
in der milchstraße die anteile der
planeten in der habitablen zone sowie
der anteil der sterne mit einem alter
von mindestens fünf milliarden jahren
diese größen konnten relativ einfach mit
hilfe von aktuellen beobachtungsdaten
errechnet werden nur eine größe musste
abgeschätzt werden
dabei ging es um die durchschnittliche
lebenszeit an der zivilisation ab dem
zeitpunkt ab dem die signale in den
weltraum schicken
diese größe muss dividiert werden durch
den zeitraum der benötigt wird damit
sich auf diesem planeten überhaupt leben
bilden kann hier schätzen die fachleute
4 bis 211 aktiv kommunizieren die
zivilisation in unserer galaxie und
ließen diese größen in verschiedenen
szenarien berechnen das ergebnis ist
eindeutig demnach sind inklusive uns
menschen 36 aktive lebensform am
wahrscheinlichsten hierbei gingen die
forscher davon aus das zitat die
wissenschaft überall im universum auf
dieselbe weise funktioniert demnach wird
sich auf jedem planeten intelligentes
leben entwickeln wenn alle kriterien
dafür wie auch auf der erde erfüllt
werden ein weiteres ergebnis dieser
spannenden studie bezieht sich auf die
wahrscheinliche entfernung einer
außerirdischen zivilisation zu unserer
erde
diese liegt demnach bei 17 tausend
lichtjahren mit der aktuellen
technologie wäre es also ausgeschlossen
eine mögliche kommunikation aufzunehmen
oder zu detektieren
doch das außerirdisches leben existiert
davon ist auch der astronom kipping
überzeugt er hat im vergangenen jahr
eine virtuelle zeitreise gemacht und
untersucht inwieweit sich organismen und
bedingungen entwickeln konkret
untersuchten die fachleute mit hilfe
statistischer verfahren
inwieweit sich die irdische evolution
unter denselben auslands bedingungen
genau so noch einmal zugetragen hätte so
spielten die us wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler quasi die erdgeschichte
bei denselben ausgangsbedingungen in
dauerschleife ab mit hilfe von
statistischen berechnungen analysierten
die fachleute dann wie häufig und wann
genau sich einfaches und auch
intelligentes leben entwickelt das
forschungsteam schreibt dazu in der
studie vom sommer 2020 das schnelle
auftauchen erster lebensform und die er
später entwicklung des menschen scheinen
auf eine gesetzmäßigkeit hinzudeuten
aber mit dieser studie können wir das
quantifizieren diese methode ist
vergleichbar mit den
wahrscheinlichkeiten beim wetten sie
erlaubt ein wiederholtes testen
ausgehend von bestehenden daten im
prinzip ist es wie eine positive
rückkopplungsschleife die die schätzung
der wahrscheinlichkeit eines ereignisses
immer weiter verfeinert das ergebnis ist
überraschend eindeutig erdähnlichen
bedingungen führen dazu dass ich
einfacher organismen sehr schnell und
häufig entwickeln und dieses ergebnis
ist nach ansicht der fachleute auch auf
andere planeten übertragbar konkret
liegt die chance dass sich einfaches
leben sehr schnell unter ähnlichen
bedingungen entwickelt bei mindestens
drei zu eins wenn man davon ausgehen
dass die ersten lebensspuren bereits von
vor vier milliarden jahren stammt steigt
die wahrscheinlichkeit nach angaben der
us fachleute sogar auf neun zu eins
die chancen für intelligente
lebensformen dagegen stehen nur drei zu
zwei im klartext spricht demnach also
einiges dafür dass planeten mit
erdähnlichen bedingungen relativ schnell
von einfachen organismen bewohnt werden
laut kipping könnte dies schon in weit
weniger als einer milliarden jahre nach
der jeweiligen planetenentstehung der
fall sein dazu david kipping
optimistisch die suche nach
intelligentem leben anderswo im als
sollte sich daher auf keinen fall davon
entmutigen lassen ganz anders dagegen
jetzt das ergebnis der aktuellen studie
der erdsystemforschung tobi terrell von
der universität southampton glaubt nicht
daran dass die suche nach außerirdischem
leben kurz vor dem durchbruch steht ganz
im gegenteil er geht davon aus dass das
schicksal der erde ein sehr
außergewöhnliches ist was er damit meint
da
auf unserem heimatplaneten seit so
langer zeit leben möglich ist ist im all
höchstwahrscheinlich ein großer zufall
mit seinem forschungsteam hat der
us-experte umfangreiche simulationen
durchgeführt hierbei wurden 100.000
planeten zufällig generiert und ganz
genau analysiert wie oft sie bei jeweils
100 durchläufen für drei milliarden
jahre lebenswert bleiben notwendig war
hierfür ein supercomputer und diese
simulation ist eine echte premiere denn
bislang waren diese immer nur für die
erde durchgeführt worden
die großen fragen des aktuellen projekts
bleiben planeten für immer lebenswert
und bleiben andere planeten für immer
nicht lebenswert die simulationen
ergaben ein eindeutiges bild nur neun
prozent der 100.000 sie monierten
planeten blieben während der 100
durchläufe für mindestens einmal drei
milliarden jahre lang abi tabel hinzu
kommt bei diesen erfolgreichen planeten
besteht ja auch keine hundertprozentige
sicherheit dafür dass für diese lange
zeit lebenswerte bedingungen existieren
das fazit von target das leben auf der
erde ist durch reinen zufall entstanden
doch dies geht eben nicht nur für die
erde sondern auch für das gesamte all
demnach ist der zufall also entscheidend
für die entstehung lebens frontier
bedingungen über einen längeren zeitraum
in dem dann tatsächlich auch leben
entstehen kann pures glück also dass wir
menschen uns entwickeln konnten demnach
also ein zufall dass unsere erde nicht
ein ähnliches schicksal erlitten hat wie
beispielsweise die planeten venus oder
mars so ist ein leben auf der venus
heutzutage völlig undenkbar mit einer
durchschnittstemperatur von rund 460
grad celsius ist es dort nicht nur heiß
genug und breit zu schmelzen
ihre atmosphäre besteht zudem auch zum
größten teil aus kohlendioxid doch in
der vergangenheit sah die venus
offensichtlich ganz anders aus bedeckt
mit ozean und somit vielleicht sogar
bewohnbar ein forschungsteam aus wales
hatte erst vor kurzem herausgefunden
dass der planet sich wohl stück für
stück zu der heutigen höllen landschaft
entwickelt hatte unsere erde hat im
laufe ihrer geschichte wohl auch mal
bedingungen geboten die möglicherweise
fast alles leben ausgerottet hätten in
der fachwelt ist von der sogenannten
schneeball erde die rede
erst im vergangenen jahr hatten
japanische forscher herausgefunden dass
die erde vor rund 800 millionen jahren
wohl mal eine der härtesten eiszeiten
überhaupt durchstehen musste damals
könnte es gigantische asteroiden
anschläge gegeben haben davon zeugen ein
stark
hatte auf dem mond die vor etwa 80
millionen jahren entstanden sein müssen
diese krassen schauer müssten dann auch
die erde getroffen haben und zwar mit
verheerendem ausmaß denn der japanische
studie zufolge muss es sich um
asteroiden mit einer masse von insgesamt
mindestens 40 bis 50 millionen tonnen
gehandelt haben
die auf der erde eingeschlagen sind das
fazit des forschungsteams um david fällt
also eher mau aus denn die neue studie
erlaubt zwar den rückschluss dass es
exoplaneten geben könnte die ähnliche
lebensbedingungen wie die erde geboten
haben
doch dann wurden sie möglicherweise zu
ungemütlich für leben vielleicht zu kalt
oder zu warm wenn man also alleine von
diesen forschungsergebnissen ausgeht
sind die erfolgsaussichten eine zweite
erde zu finden eher minimal allerdings
würde ich dagegen halten wenn die
chancen für einen sternensystem gering
sind dass ich dort leben entwickeln kann
ist aber milliarden sternensysteme in
jeder galaxie und von galaxien billionen
gibt dann sehen die chancen wiederum
nicht ganz so schlecht aus oder was
meint ihr gibt es aliens oder nicht ich
diskutiere hier heute am erscheinungstag
des videos weiß ich mit ich bin auf eure
meinung hier unterm video gespannt
andere alien forschende meinen
jedenfalls womöglich ein alien signal
sogar detektiert zu haben allen signal
bsc one ist der erste offizielle
anerkannte kandidat ziemlich spektakulär
also aber können wir heute auch gerne
diskutieren also vorher anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren
und natürlich dem podcast auch bis dann
bleibt dran